[Music]
one of the few screenwriters to
transcend his profession Charlie Kaufman
is responsible for some of the most
unique daring and inventive screenplays
in contemporary cinema beginning with
Being John Malkovich she rapidly
established himself as a unique talent
following up with adaptation and Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind before
making his directorial debut with
Synecdoche New York of his six
screenplays that have been made into
films three have one BAFTAs for Best
Original Screenplay this film's deal
with identity mortality relationships
and the meaning or purpose of life they
are metaphysical self reflexive hyper
aware often using surrealist conceit to
explore our fundamental anxieties it is
in this tradition of finding new
startling and funny ways of exploring
human psychology
the Charlie Kaufman sits comfortably
amongst the world's greatest living
writers
you
I've never delivered a speech before
which is why I decided to do this I
wanted to do something that I don't know
how to do and offer you the experience
of watching someone fumble because I
think maybe that's what art should offer
an opportunity to recognize our common
humanity and vulnerability so rather
than being up here pretending I'm an
expert in anything or presenting myself
in a way that will reinforce the odd
ritualized lecturer lecturer model I'm
just telling you off the bat that I
don't know anything and if there's one
thing that characterizes my writing is
that I always start from that
realization and I do what I can to keep
reminding myself of that during the
process I think we try to be experts
because we're scared we don't want to
feel foolish or worthless we want power
because power is a great disguise
I even feel odd calling myself a writer
or a screenwriter I do when I have to I
put it on my income tax form but I feel
like it's a lie even though it's
technically true I write screenplays for
a living but it's not what I am when I
was young I really wanted that label I
wanted to be something you know I wanted
to be a writer there's this movie
Serpico and there was a scene in Serpico
where um you know Al Pacino is a cop and
he has an artist girlfriend and there's
a party scene where he's with all these
different artist types and they're
saying you know well I'm a I'm a painter
but I work in a restaurant and I'm a I'm
an actor but I you know worked in an
office and this goes on for a while now
Pacino says I'm a cop and I work for the
police department
and um but there was that feeling when
you say you're something when you want
to say you're something and you have
nothing to back it up because everybody
says they're a writer or everybody says
they're this or they're that and this is
this is what I felt and everyone else
thinks it's [ __ ] it's funny now that
I don't want to call myself that but at
the time I did and I think I I think
that it was necessary at the time but at
now it doesn't feel necessary because I
think the thing I realized is that I'm
not those things you know I'm I'm I'm a
person who does this and I struggle with
it I think it was Thomas Monde who said
that a writer is someone for whom
writing is harder than it is for other
people which you know I thought was
pretty cool
I I'm and I think that it I think that
sort of ed is that you know if you take
it seriously it's a struggle and it's
interesting to me that I've been
struggling with this speech for a long
time I told them that I would do this
months and months ago and I've been this
has been my job in a way I said at my
desk and I don't know what to do and it
is very much like when I have a job
writing a screenplay I think I wanted to
do something true when I wanted to do
something helpful and I think that what
what complicates it in addition to the
fact that that's a hard thing to figure
out is that I also struggle with wanting
you to like me and um you know in my
fantasy I leave here and people are
saying great speech you know and not
only is he a great writer but boy you
know I really learned something tonight
he really brought it you know and so as
much as I know that this neediness of
mine exists I also also have a difficult
time extricate myself from it or even
fully recognizing it when it's happening
because it's a tricky thing it's I mean
no one wants to come up here and bomb
it's really literally the stuff of
nightmares you know I've had that
nightmare a lot of times and um and I
know you want to be entertained and so
for me to calculatedly not entertain you
in order to be true seem sort of selfish
so I find myself in this push-pull
relationship with my opposing desires
which I think you know is a big part of
what characters are and characters do in
in in real life people in real life
characters and movies should okay I know
you think this is just one of my
get-rich-quick schemes
I'm doing it right this time I'm taking
a three day seminar and it's only five
bucks screenwriting seminars are
[ __ ] I mean I've had the good
fortune of working with directors who
have been very collaborative with me so
that I've been I've been I've had a
voice in most of the things that I've
written that I didn't direct but you
know I do feel like I wanted to take the
step to direct things as well not
because of dissatisfaction with with
those movies but just you know I just I
like the idea of it of having that kind
of ultimate control here's a quote that
I found a recent quote that I found we
do not talk we bludgeon one another with
facts and theories gleaned from cursory
readings of newspapers magazines and
digests that was actually written in
1945 by Henry Miller and I mean I think
it's timely and I think what it says is
that the world has been on the present
course it's on for a long time people
all over the world spend countless hours
of their lives every week being fed
entertainment in the forms of movies TV
shows newspapers YouTube videos
the Internet and it's ludicrous to
believe that the stuff doesn't alter our
brains and it's also equally ludicrous
to believe that at the very least this
mass distraction and manipulation is not
convenient for the people who are in
charge people are starving they may not
know it because they're being fed
mass-produced garbage the packaging is
colorful and it's loud but it's being
produced in the same factories that make
pop-tarts and iPads by people sitting
around thinking what can we do what can
we do to get people to buy more of these
and they're very good at their jobs but
that's what it is you're getting because
that's what they're making they're
selling you something and the world is
built on this now politics and
government are built on this
corporations are built on this
interpersonal relationships are built on
this and we're starving all of us and
we're killing each other
and we're hitting each other and we're
calling each other liars and evil
because it's all become marketing and we
want to win because we're lonely and
empty and scared and we're led to
believe winning will change all that
but there is no winning what can be done
say who you are really say it in your
life and in your work tell someone out
there who is lost someone not yet born
someone who won't be born for five
hundred years your writing will be a
record of your time it can't help but be
but more importantly if you're honest
about who you are you'll help that
person be less lonely in their world
because that person will recognize him
or herself in you and that will give
them hope and it's done so for me and I
have to keep rediscovering it it's
profound importance in my life give that
to the world rather than selling
something to the world don't allow
yourself to be tricked into thinking
that the way things are is the way the
world must work and that in the end
selling is what everyone must do try not
to
this is a from EE Cummings to be nobody
but yourself in a world which is doing
its best night and day to make you
everybody else means to fight the
hardest battle which any human being can
fight and never stop fighting the world
needs you
it doesn't need you at a party having
read a book about how to appear smart at
parties these books exist and they're
tempting but resist falling into that
trap the world needs you at the party
starting real conversations saying I
don't know being kind
[Music]
my first writing job was on a TV show
called get a life starring Chris Elliot
the show was really mostly in the voice
of its creators Chris Elliot and Adam
Resnick they had a they had worked
together on David Letterman Show and
Chris's character came from that show so
consequently Adam Resnick scripts were
the best in of the show and we all tried
to write an atom's voice that was the
job and I was frustrated with my results
but it occurred to me that there was no
solution to this problem as long as my
job was trying to imitate someone else's
voice I could maybe get close but I was
never going to get better at it than
Adam the obvious solution was not to
throw my hands up but try to find myself
in a situation where I was doing me not
someone else do you it isn't easy but
it's essential it's not easy because
there's a lot in the way in many cases a
major obstacle is you're deeply seated
belief that you is not interesting
and since convincing yourself that you
are interesting is probably not going to
happen take it off the table agree
perhaps I'm not interesting but I am the
only thing I have to offer and I want to
offer something and by offering myself
in a true way I am doing a great service
to the world because it is rare and it
will help as I move through time things
change I change the world changes the
way the world sees me changes I age I
fail I succeed I am lost I have a moment
of calm the remnants of who I have been
however hover depressed me embarrass me
make me wistful the inkling of who I
will be depresses me makes me hopeful
scares me embarrasses me and here I
stand at this crossroads always
embarrassed
wistful depressed angry longing looking
back looking forward I may make a
decision and move from that crossroads
at which point I find myself instantly
at another crossroads therefore there is
only movement a scream
is movement it is written in time and
expresses a passage of time it is made
in time and it is viewed in time it's a
movie it moves that's two hours I'll
never get back
it's a favorite thing for an angry
person to say about a movie he hates but
the thing is every two hours or two
hours he'll never get back
you cannot horde your two hours is so
you are here and I am here spending our
time as we must it must be spent I am
trying not to spend this time as I spend
most of my time trying to get you to
like me trying to control your thoughts
to use my voodoo at the speed of light
the speed of sound at the speed of
thought trying to convince you that your
two hours with me are not going to be
resented afterwards it is an ancient
pattern of time usage for me and I'm
trying to move deeper hoping to be
helpful
this pattern of time usage pays paints
over an ancient wound and paints it with
bright colors
it's a sleight of hand a distraction so
to attempt to change the pattern
let me expose the wound I now step into
this area blindly I do not know what the
wound is I do know that it is old I do
know that it is a hole in my being I do
know it is tender I do believe that it
is unknowable or at least in articulable
I do believe you have a wound too I do
believe it is both specific to you and
common to everyone I do believe it is
the thing about you that must be hidden
and protected it is the thing that is
tap-danced over five shows a day it is
the thing that won't be interesting to
other people if revealed it is the thing
that makes you weak and pathetic it is
the thing that truly truly truly makes
loving you impossible it is your secret
even from yourself but it is the thing
that wants to live it is the thing from
which your art your painting your dance
your composition your philosophical
treatise your screenplay is born if you
don't acknowledge this you will come up
here when it is your time and you will
give your speech and you will talk about
the business of screenwriting you will
say that as a screenwriter you are a cog
in a business machine you will say it is
not an art form you will say here this
is what a screenplay looks like you will
discuss character arcs how to make
likable characters you will talk about
box office this is what you will do this
is who
you will be and after you're done I will
feel lonely and empty and hopeless I
like when people like my things I mean I
don't I mean I'm not crazy well I am
crazy but I'm not that crazy but you
know but but i but it has to be on the
terms that makes sense to me I wanted I
want to like it if other people like it
that's really good and and great because
it means that something that I've said
has somehow you know resonated with
somebody and that's that's amazing I
want that but but it has to be the thing
that I've said when I first started to
work in series television I didn't need
to take a course on how to write a
half-hour comedy I knew because I had
been raised as a consumer of TV series I
understood the rhythms
I understood the types of jokes that
were acceptable I understood the stock
characters and of course all of this was
in service of the perpetuation of the
same consumer culture that trained me
and made me desire to be part of it I
was a zombie
it's a massive issue because the
business I'm in is the same business
that politicians and corporations are in
it's a business of selling something
that's important to them by disguising
it as something that's important to you
and it's ubiquitous and I don't think
it's symbiotic what I'm trying to
express what I'd like to express is the
notion that by being honest thoughtful
and aware of the existence of other
living beings a change can begin to
happen in how we think of ourselves and
the world and ourselves in the world we
are not the passive audience for this
big messed up power play we don't have
to be we can say who we are we can
assert our right to existence we can say
to the bullies and con men the people
who try to shame us embarrass us flatter
us to the people have no compunction
about lying to us to get our money and
our Allegiance that we are thinking
really thinking about who we are and
we'll express ourselves and with this
other people won't feel so alone this is
Harold Pinter a writers life is a highly
vulnerable almost naked activity we
don't have to weep about that the writer
makes this choice and is stuck with it
but it is true to say that you are open
to all the winds some of them I see
indeed you're out on your own out on a
limb you find no shelter no protection
unless you lie in which case of course
you have constructed your own protection
and it could be argued become a
politician it's weird to be a human we
get to think about things we get to
wonder this seems like quite a
privileged position in the universe and
I wouldn't give it up for certainty
because when you're certain you stop
being curious and here's the one thing I
know about the thing you're certain
about you're wrong of course this is a
paradox how is it possible to know that
you can't know anything it isn't it's
just a theory and I remain open to being
proven wrong
think about your reaction to me think
past it why do you have that reaction
why do you react this way to certain
things what does your reaction have to
do with your wants how does it correlate
how would you how would you reaction to
what I'm saying change if I were older
younger female a different race British
what does it mean about you that it
would change what does it mean about the
subjective subjectivity of your opinions
what if I was me but had a different
demeanor what if I was more confident
less confident what if I was more
effeminate what if I was less effeminate
what if I was drunk what if I was on the
verge of tears think about all the
assessments all the interpretations that
occur with each react interaction think
about all that you bring to each
encounter multiply that by all the
people here how much is going on in this
room and how do we weave that into a
movie the challenge of multiple points
of view forces us to come up with new
solutions to throw away conventional
approaches movies tend to be very
concrete in their construction of events
and characters it's a tricky medium in
which to deal with interior lives but I
think it's really a great medium for it
movies share so much with dreams which
of course only deal with interior lives
your brain is wired to turn emotional
states into movie
your dreams are very well written I know
this without knowing any of you people
turn anxieties crises and longing love
regret and guilt into beautiful rich
stories in their dreams what is it that
allows us the creative freedom in our
dreams that we don't have in our waking
lives I don't know but I suspect part of
it is that in our dreams we are not
constricted by worry about how we will
appear to others it's a private
conversation with ourselves and if we're
worried about it this becomes part of
the dream I think if we were better able
to approach our artwork this way the
results would be different so what is a
screen player what might it be since we
were talking specifically about
screenplays tonight a screenplay is an
exploration it's about the thing you
don't know to step into the abyss it's
necessary necessarily start somewhere
anywhere there is a starting point but
the rest is undetermined it is a secret
even from you there's no template for a
screenplay or there shouldn't be there
are at least as many screenplay
possibilities as there are people who
write them we've been conned into
thinking there is a pre-established form
like any big business the film business
believes in mass production it's cheaper
and more efficient as a business model
but I don't want to talk about that
aspect of screenwriting here's what I
know about a screenplay simply that is a
text that describes what happens in a
movie and I'm not even sure about this
definition I think what might make this
form of endeavor exciting for writers is
that they find themselves in an
environment where they are encouraged to
use their powers to explore the world
their minds and the form itself think
about the staggering possibilities the
marriage of light vibration and time I
think craft is a dangerous thing
I saw a trailer did you call them
trailers here I saw a trailer for a
movie and I won't say what the movie is
but it's coming out soon and it was
gorgeous and it was gorgeous it was
gorgeous it was gorgeous it was like
it's gorgeous and it made me really
depressed and I was trying to sort of
figure out why I think there was an
amazing amount of craft and skill on the
part of the filmmakers in this in this
movie and and yet it was the same [ __ ]
and I know that this movie is going to
do really well and I know that the
people who made it are going to get
rewarded for it and and so the cycle
continues so I think the danger of craft
is that it needs to be in second
position to what it is that you're doing
and and it and it's seductive to put it
in first position often because what
you're doing is meaningless or worthless
or just more of the same and so you can
distinguish yourself by being very very
good at it I think you need to be
willing to be naked when you do anything
creatively in film or in any other form
that's really what you have to do
because it's because
because otherwise it's very very hard to
separate it from marketing I think that
it just sort of becomes what it's about
it's just that I told myself not to say
Pope Alexander and sound like a dope and
then I go ahead and like it's no big
deal
you're such a sweetheart I always try to
do something that I don't know how to do
when I always try to do something
different but you know I'm a person with
a very specific existence and a very
specific background and like everybody
is and the stuff that comes out of me
might resemble other things that I've
come out of me you know but um but I
don't I don't try for that in fact I try
for the opposite you know I put this
thing that I just wrote that hopefully
it's going to get made is is is a
musical you know and I've never done
that before so so I did it the speaker
stands on the stage he looks out at the
audience he doesn't really know why he's
here not really more and more in his
life he finds himself in places he can't
explain not really explained he knows
he's here to give a speech and he's told
himself he intends to do some good with
it but he knows that reason crumbles to
dust under investigation what he wants
us to change who he is
each predicament such as this one each
challenge he accepts he accepts in order
to move him to the next level of
truthfulness each time he goes in hoping
he will come out a real person he knows
if he just takes enough risks eventually
he will be something something that
lives a real life sweat forms on his
brow how did I know it's amazing
you know cuz I wrote this a week ago so
he is to speak on a subject he has been
chosen as an expert but the subject is
unclear to him and he's lonely is the
truth on it he feels trapped under
burdens so immense the history he
carries the thwarted relationships the
compromised relationships the longing
that drapes him like a shroud the wand
he is a wanting machine ever wanting he
looks out at the audience they don't
know what to make of him why is he
reading this story up there he is to be
giving a speech about screenwriting
someone in the audience is happy a train
wreck is in progress and he is
witnessing it speaker knows this he
believes he has considered every
possible audience reaction he wants to
be liked by them he wants to be admired
and adored he wants to be found
attractive he hates himself for this
this is the stuff that it always comes
down to and his goal here tonight was to
be different he wants to be real real in
this contrived place but he can't be the
truth suddenly stares him in the face
this is who he is this is the real him
this needy wanting thing up here for the
same aggrandizement as everyone else who
does this look at me but the pain and
hollowness is real the pain that
stretches back into the haze that is his
childhood he leaves that's it it's
nothing like anything he has ever done
he walks off the stage people have paid
money he thinks as he leaves this will
be on YouTube
I am finished he returns to his hotel
and sits at the bar there is no hope
left I read an article about bullying
recently everyone is up in arms about
bullying a vocal minority thinks it's a
good thing
that it's part of growing up that it
builds character what was left out of
this article and doesn't seem to be part
of discussion is that bullying is a
significant element of our culture the
bullying of children by children doesn't
come from nowhere the question remains
whether bullying is an inherent aspect
of human nature but that doesn't change
the fact that a culture that discourages
rather than encourages bullying would
have a better chance of curbing it our
culture is marketing this is what we do
and what is marketing trying to get
people to do what you want them to it's
what drives our consumer culture it's
what drives our politics of which what
drives our art music movies books Fine
Arts it's part of every research grant
proposal I don't want to participate I
don't want to tell you how to sell a
screenplay or tell you how to write a
hit or tell you how to fit into the
existing system I want to tell you that
I have a hope that there's another way
to be in this world and that I believe
with courage and vulnerability and
honesty that the stuff we put into the
world can serve a better purpose the
movies the way movies work now and I'm
talking about mainstream industry the
only goal is to get you to buy a product
the only goal the only goal the only
goal the only goal and this intention
creates the movies that we sit through
and this move the movies that we sit
through create us in government we've
been reduced to the same game through
trickery obfuscation bullying
fear-mongering
the goal of marketing a candidate is
achieved I don't know I don't understand
many things I don't know as much as I'd
like about anything but I'm a human
being and I won't be in competition for
the right to be treated decently I won't
play that game nor should anybody have
to and in turn I will try not to use
whatever access I have to the public
sphere to sell things including myself
the world is very scary now it always
has been but something grotesque and
specific to our time is blanketing us we
need to see that it is not reality it is
a choice we're making or allowing other
people to make for us
you are born into a body into a family
into a situation into a brain chemistry
into a gender into a culture into a time
as am i at times I can feel the massive
gravitational pulling of all these
various things pulling me in different
directions creating me I watch the
reactions I have that are as much my
father's as they are mine
I know they are inherited through genes
and situation just as they have been
from my father and I feel immense
loneliness of this prison coupled with a
great shame because I can see that this
prison has an open door but I can't get
through it how weak I am how can I not
be a saint or a person a healthier
person a more generous person my sneaker
comfort company tells me that I can and
that it's up to me it is a sign of great
weakness if I don't just do it and these
are the priests of our culture the
therapists the dad with a firm hand but
your best interests at heart a sneaker
company that runs sweatshops in
third-world countries this is our dad
and I don't know about you but I can be
moved to tears by these commercials that
these people put out and I think it's
despicable
[Music]
I like that I like the idea of the job a
lot I mean I I don't want it sort of
like you know they I get to think about
things I want to think about I get to
you know I get to write jokes that
sometimes make people laugh and I mean
it's a great job but it's very hard for
me it's very it's like it's not I don't
you know I don't sit at my desk and and
laughs yeah um that's very very rare you
know mostly I I sit I sit at my desk and
look at stuff online it's mostly what I
do
because I can't think
allow your screenplay to grow and change
as you work on it you will discover
things as you work you must not put
these things aside even if they are
inconvenient
let's not disregard all the little
voices in order to simplify do not
simplify let's not worry about what it
looks like let's not worry about failure
failure is a badge of honor
it means you risked failure and if you
don't risk failure you're never going to
do anything that's different than what
you've already done
or what somebody else has done and just
know that that that's the choice you're
making when when you won't put yourself
at jeopardy like that don't
compartmentalize to make things simpler
than they are and don't work towards
results allow yourself time let things
brew you're thinking about it whether
you realize it or not letting the
unconscious take over brings in freedom
and surprise and removes judgment at
every single moment every single person
wants something often many things often
conflicting things understand this about
your characters and yourself
storytelling is inherently dangerous if
you consider a traumatic event in your
life consider it as you experienced it
now think about how you told it to
someone a year later now think about how
you told it for the 100th time it's not
the same thing a few components enter
into the change one is perspective most
people think perspective is a good thing
to have in a story you can figure out
character arcs you can apply a moral you
can tell it from a distance with
understanding and context the problem is
that this perspective is a
misrepresentation of the incident it's a
reconstruction with meaning and as such
bears very little resemblance to the
event the other thing that happens in
storytelling is the process of
adjustment for the audience over time
you find out which part of the story's
story works which parts to embellish
which parts to jettison you fashion it
your goal your ease
for telling it are to be entertaining to
garner sympathy this is true for a story
told at a dinner party and it's true for
stories told in movies there's so many
there are so many pitfalls when a movie
comes out that it's hard it's hard to
enjoy it when it comes out I mean
obviously if a movie does well and
critically you know it well received and
I like it
I like it but I'm so I'm so needful of
it that kind of response that I don't
think it doesn't feel good
it just feels less bad you know it's
because it feels really bad when people
say mean things really it feels bad yeah
and I kind of wish that it didn't but it
does and it does for me and so so that's
me
I don't tell me Mapplethorpe Malcom
Malkovich right okay with a screenplay
you're creating a world consider
everything every character every room
every juxtaposition every increment of
time as an embodiment of that world look
at all of this through that filter and
make sure it is all consistent as in a
painting every element is part of one
whole composition just that there's
nothing separate in the actual world
there should be nothing separate in the
world you create I tell you this little
story now because it's interesting to me
and I don't know why I'm telling it but
it's interesting to me and it's sort of
um it just seems like there's something
inherently cinematic about it I run in
my neighborhood and and one day I ran
past this guy who's running in the other
direction an older guy and I'm big you
know hulky kind of guy really struggling
to you know huffing and puffing and I
was kind of going down a slight hill and
he was coming up the hill it was very
slight and he's wearing like a headband
and he's sweatshirt
and so he passes me and he goes well
sure it's all downhill that way and um
and I love that I love that joke you
know because um cuz it's funny you know
because it's a funny joke and he made a
connection and it was like a witty sort
of witty thing to say and so I had my
head that I like this guy this is a cool
guy you know and he's and he's my friend
now and uh and so like a few weeks later
I'm passing by him again I see him I see
him in the distance coming toward me
we're going opposite ways and I'm
thinking oh there's the guy you know
that's cool and so as we pass each other
he says well sure it's all downhill that
way and I was like okay you know he's
got a he's got a repertoire and you know
doesn't doesn't know um you know I mean
I'm not that I'm not that special you
know he's probably said it to other
people maybe he doesn't remember me he
doesn't remember his an older guy maybe
there's some you know and so um but okay
you know hahaha I laugh but this time it
was a little forced my laugh because I
got all these things going on in my head
I'm disappointed and then I passed him
again and he says it again and this time
he's going downhill and I'm going uphill
and so I'm like it doesn't even make any
sense anymore it's not even it's not
about anything and I started to have so
much pain about this because I'm
embarrassed for him and I and I any and
and there's something wrong with him I
think
you know and and then it just keeps
happening and um
it's all downhill that way
probably heard it seven or eight more
times and I start to avoid him I see him
coming and I crossed the street because
I you know you know and if I can't cross
the street then I you know I look like
I'm really focused on my running you
know just and he says it anyway if he
passes me and even if I'm not looking
and um I don't why I'm telling you the
story except that I like the I like the
idea that changes over time and nothing
has changed you know what's changed is
all in my head and and has to do with
with a realization on my characters part
through time of it's there's no there's
no outward story here you know and it
only again it can only be told in a form
it can't be told in a painting I guess
is the point I'm making I wouldn't know
how to do that and I think that you know
that's that's sort of I mean I'm
probably reaching here to sort of say
this but I do think that you know that
that when you're doing a movie when
you're doing a screenplay you have to
know why it's a movie and if it doesn't
have to be a movie then you shouldn't
make it because it's very important that
what you do is specific to the medium in
which you're doing it and that you
utilize what's specific about that
medium to do the work and if you can't
if you can't think about why it should
be done this way or needs to be done
this way then it doesn't need to be done
this way and then you should figure out
what it is about this if you want to do
it that needs to be told in the form of
a movie
I sincerely hope that I have something
of interest or value to say tonight I
can't tell anyone how to write a
screenplay because the truth is that
anything of value you might do comes
from you the way I work is not the way
that you work and the whole point of any
creative act is that what I have to
offer is me what you have to offer is
you and if you offer yourself without
authenticity and generosity I will be
moved
[Music]
you
[Music]